aquí tenemos la gráfica de una función
fx y lo que quiero que hagamos en este
vídeo es esbozar dicha gráfica a partir
de la definición de la función que está
dada por esta expresión por esta
expresión racional 2x + 10 sobre 5x
menos 15 hay un par de maneras de hacer
esto lo primero que podemos hacer es
escoger algunos números para los cuales
sea fácil evaluar la función por ejemplo
qué sucede cuando x es igual a cero
tenemos entonces que f de 0 es igual
estos términos se hacen 0 y nos queda 10
sobre menos 15 o lo que es lo mismo
menos dos tercios menos dos tercios
vamos a graficar entonces cuando x vale
0 que vale menos dos tercios aquí lo
tenemos déjame graficar lo con un color
más oscuro aquí está el valor debe de
ser igual a menos dos tercios también
podemos ver cuando la función se hace
cero bien la función se hace cero la
única manera de que la función se haga
cero es cuando el numerador es igual a
cero resolvemos la ecuación
2 x 10 y 0 esto nos da 2 x igual a menos
10 restamos 10 a ambos lados de la
ecuación dividimos entre 2 ambos lados
para obtener entonces x es igual a menos
5 y eso esto lo podemos ver aquí cuando
x es igual a menos 5 la función
intersecta el eje de las x pero eso son
tan sólo dos puntos eso no nos da la
forma general de esta interesante
función y aquí podrías pensar qué tipo
de funciones tienen una forma semejante
a ésta ahora lo que quiero considerar es
el comportamiento de la función en
distintos puntos primero quiero ver
cuando esta función no está definida y
qué sucede
cómo se comporta esta función cuando no
está definida la única manera para que
esta función no esté definida es cuando
el denominador es igual a cero no
sabemos lo que significa dividir un
número entre cero así es que la función
está definida cuando 5x deje ponerlo en
azul 5x menos 15 es igual a 0 o lo que
es lo mismo sumando 15 ambos lados 5x es
igual a 15
/ 5x es igual a tres cuando x es igual a
efe no está definida hay dos razones por
las cuales una función no está definida
en un punto podríamos tener algo así voy
a dibujar aquí unos ejes cartesianos
suponemos que aquí está x igual a 3 aquí
podría estar definida la función tender
a este valor no está definida en este
punto y luego continuar por acá la otra
posibilidad es que tenga una cinta
vertical ahí si tuviera una cinta
vertical se vería más o menos así podría
ir creciendo por aquí tendiendo hacia
infinito y quizá después de tres de
crecer desde infinito hoy creciendo
desde menos infinito venir desde menos
infinito por aquí así es como se ve una
sin tota vertical a medida que nos
acercamos por la izquierda la gráfica se
aproxima una vertical sin llegar nunca
al valor de x igual a 3 la función no
está definida en x igual a 3 y cuando te
aproximas por la derecha también la
gráfica llega cerca
en este caso cae aproximándose a menos
infinito cuando x se aproxima a 3 por la
derecha entonces como sabríamos
obviamente cuando lo ves aquí ya
teniendo la gráfica veamos aquí tenemos
el 10 aquí tendríamos 2 4 6 8 10 más o
menos por aquí está el 3 aquí tenemos
una sin tota vertical una sin tota
vertical
x 3
x igual a 3 vamos a escribirlo por acá
vamos a escribirlo aquí arriba que
tenemos una asiento está vertical
asiento está vertical en x igual a 3
pero como sabrías esto cómo sabrías esto
si no tuvieras la gráfica aquí tan solo
teniendo esto sabemos que no está
definida en 3 pero como sabemos que no
es un punto de discontinuidad en vez de
una cinta vertical hay un par de maneras
de hacer esto una de ellas es tomar
valores cerca de 3 y ver cómo se
comporta la función por ejemplo sacamos
la calculadora podemos probar digamos
con 3.01 entonces vamos a evaluar la
función que sería 2 x 3.01 + 10 este es
el numerador dividido entre 5 x 3.01
menos 15 y esto es igual a 320 punto 4
es un número bastante grande vamos a ver
qué pasa si tomamos una x
grande digamos 3.001 entonces 2 x 3.001
ya eso le sumamos 10 y ahora dividimos
todo esto entre 5 x 3.001 ese es el
valor de x que estamos probando ahora
3.001 ya eso le restamos 15 observa
hemos obtenido un número aún mayor a
medida que x se acerca 3 el valor de fx
es cada vez mayor
fx está atendiendo infinito así es que
tenemos que por este lado la gráfica de
la función está atendiendo infinito
podríamos dibujar entonces este trazo
este trazo de aquí veamos ahora qué pasa
con valores menores que son cercanos a 3
digamos por ejemplo 2.999 mejor voy a
hacer lo siguiente voy a tomar la
expresión anterior y voy a poner ahora
el nuevo valor de x ahora x vale 2.999
también cambiamos el valor de x en el
denominador 2.999
evaluamos la expresión y obtenemos
tenemos un valor negativo muy grande la
función está atendiendo a menos infinito
con ese valor tenemos indicios de que la
función se ve más o menos así y además
coincide con los dos valores que ya
habíamos graficado previamente y ahora
veamos qué pasa a medida que x toma
valores muy grandes tanto positivos como
negativos parece ser que hay un asiento
está horizontal al ver la gráfica
notamos que aquí hay una sintonía son
tal a medida que x toma valores
positivos muy grandes
efe x se va aproximar a este valor por
arriba de la 5ta y a medida que x se
hace más negativo efe x se aproxima por
abajo de la 5ta y cómo podemos saber
esto simplemente viendo la función bien
hagamos un experimento mental para ver
qué pasa con la función a medida que x
toma valores cada vez más grandes
déjame escribir eso cuando x tiende a
infinito
fx tiende a qué valor a medida que x
toma valores cada vez más grandes el 10
y el menos 15 van a afectar menos y los
términos de mayor orden en el numerador
y el denominador son los que van a
dominar así que cuando x tiende a
infinito fx es aproximadamente igual a
2x sobre 5x y esto es igual a dos
quintos podemos decir entonces que fx
tiende a dos quintos ahora para ver esto
claramente vemos valores a x cada vez
más grandes y verifiquemos que la
función se aproxima a dos quintos así es
que si tenemos aquí vamos a tener equis
y aquí fx empecemos con x igual a 1 f x
es igual a 2 + 10 sobre 5 menos 15 y
aquí el 10 y el menos 15 influyen
bastante pero si x es igual a 1000 fx es
entonces 2000
más diez sobre cinco mil menos quince y
aquí dos mil cinco mil son los que
determinan principalmente el valor de fx
si x fuera por ejemplo un millón si x
fuera un millón y aquí loa pone en azul
para que haya mayor contraste fx sería
dos millones más 10 sobre sobre 5
millones menos 15 y aquí realmente 10 y
menos 15 no importan para nada imagínate
si esto fuera un billón o un trillón o
un 4 y jon 10 y menos 15 serían
realmente irrelevantes así es que a
medida que existiendo infinito estos
términos no importan los términos de
mayor orden son los que pesan fx va a
tender a 2x sobre 5x que es igual a 2
quintos
así es que fx tiende a dos quintos que
es donde parece que se ubica esta línea
dos quintos es igual a 0.4 aquí lo vemos
entonces en la gráfica fx se está
aproximando a esta recta nunca llega
alcanza
este valor nunca llega a ser dos quintos
porque al final de cuentas existen estos
términos existen este más diez y este
menos quince que impiden que la función
llegue a ser exactamente dos quintos y
lo mismo sucede a medida que x es cada
vez más y más negativo podemos hacer
todos estos valores negativos cuando x
es igual a menos 1
este sería menos 2 sobre menos 5 cuando
es igual a menos 1000 éste sería menos
2000 sobre menos 5000 cuando es menos un
millón esto es menos 2 millones sobre
menos 5 millones es decir al final de
cuentas la función tiende a menos 2x
sobre menos 5x que es igual a menos 2
sobre menos 5 lo cual es igual a dos
quintos y eso es lo que estamos viendo
aquí en la gráfica tenemos entonces que
esta función tiene una a sin tota a sin
tota horizontal a sin tota horizontal
y es esta recta horizontal de igual a
dos quintos definitivamente esta gráfica
nos está ayudando a ver lo que son las
asiento estás verticales y horizontales
de la función pero si no tuviéramos la
gráfica podríamos haber establecido que
la función está definida en x igual a 3
probar algunos valores para ver que la
función tiende a menos infinito a medida
que nos acercamos a x igual a 3 por la
izquierda que la función tiende a más
infinito cuando nos acercamos a x igual
a 3 por la derecha como le indique esa
fecha podemos graficar estos puntos
cuando f es igual a 0 que pasa cuando x
es igual a 0 y también podríamos
considerar el comportamiento cuando x
tiende a infinito y a menos infinito el
valor de la función cuando x tiende a
infinito o menos infinito nos permite
establecer esta cinta horizontal con
todos esos elementos hubiéramos podido
haber hecho un buen esbozo de esta
gráfica